hello in this video I'll be discussing
the concept about the super antigens so
as the name suggests super antigens a
little bit different from the normal
antigens and itself some bacteria
produce super antigens to confuse the
immune system by producing a situation
which is equal equivalent to a false
alarm so it it's kind of a protective
mechanism by which some bacteria and
some cases some viruses are able to
confuse the body's immune system just to
save their ass now let's say there is a
particular bacterial antigen now the
t-cell would mount a specific response
against this antigen and the way t-cell
can recognize this antigen with the help
of antigen presenters right but this
kind of super antigens creates a error
in this specific detection system
instead then nonspecifically
allow proliferation of the t-cell
activation of the t-cell now once the T
cells are non specifically active they
secrete huge amount of cytokines that
brings about many other immune cells
like macrophages cos no pill mast cells
etc into the specific region as a result
huge inflammatory response is evoked but
point to be noted is that inflammatory
response is a nonspecific response so
that specific defense system or the
specific counter system against a
particular pathogen is bypassed and
that's a pathogen survival mechanism
that many bacteria used one such example
is Staphylococcus aureus toxic shock
toxin that is also a super antigen let's
just take a look how super antigen is
different from a normal antigen how does
their work and super antigen overall
create a chaos in the immune system now
let's say there is a bacterial invasion
in the body and this bacteria would be
engulfed by the macrophages or the
dendritic cell
some bacterial antigens are going to be
chewed up and presented by the class 2
MHC molecules to the T helper cells and
all these antigens are processed inside
the macrophages and they are bound in
the peptide binding groove of the MHC
class 2 molecules and as a result
selective T helper cell population a
cohort and and that cohort of the T
helper cell population is almost 1 to 2
percent of the whole t-cell population
so that selective pool of T cells would
be activated that would ultimately wait
B cells and that B cells would
differentiate into plasma cells to give
rise to specific immune response but
what super antigen does is it binds
laterally to the MHC molecule and the T
helper cells T cell receptor so the T
cell receptor and the MHC interaction is
a lateral laterally breached by this
kind of super antigens now these super
antigens are not engulfed by the
bacteria they are not processed inside
they are not engulfed by the macrophages
and they are not processed inside the
macrophages as if they are not even
experienced by the macrophages and they
are never represented in the peptide
binding groove as a result it would
activate non-specifically
all the T cells but these T cells would
secrete specific inflammatory cytokines
like il-1 il-6 TNF alpha etcetera and
all these things can mount a overall
don't specific inflammatory response now
from the bacterial side this is pretty
much advantageous because when the
immune system is non specifically active
there is a huge confusion in the immune
system what to attack or what not to
attack and the probability that the
immune system would selectively attack
that particular pathogen is reduced so
it's a beneficial part from the pathogen
side but people still doubt that what is
the beneficial side of this kind of
super antigen basic mazed nonspecific
activation of the
she sells in terms of the body but no
more of the less the body is getting
harmed by this kind of activation not a
kind of benefited because after the
super antigens are capable of activating
at least 20 to 30 percent of the T cells
of our body wherever specific antigen
can only activate one or two percent so
this huge nonspecific activation changes
the micro environment where the immune
responses would happen now let's look at
our details we're super antigen binds
super antigen binds to the Alpha region
of the t-cell receptor and variable
alpha region of the MHC molecule
laterally and breach the interaction and
it ultimately generates a false alarm
now the consequence of super antigen
mediated nonspecific t-cell activation
or overall immune activation is
inflammation sometime redness even fever
can be evoked and at chronic cases there
could be dead now the super antigens are
roughly categorized into two categories
one is endogenous super antigen and
another is exogenous for exogenous super
antigens are mostly some bacterial
exotoxins like staphylococcal
enterotoxins toxic syndrome toxins
produced by cephalic of cos aureus and
many other dermatitis toxin etc but
endogenous toxins endogenous super
antigens are basically membrane proteins
that are produced by viral genes some
retro viral genes which are some point
of the time integrated into the host
genome one such example is mammary grand
mammary gland tumor virus so which give
rise to a specific membrane bound
antigen known as minor lymphocyte
stimulating determinants or mi D that
can lead to huge nonspecific t-cell
interaction T cell activation and
overall non specific chaos in the immune
system so
that was my video about super antigens
if you liked this video and find this
information
share among your friends and don't
forget to like share and subscribe to my
channel thank you